mine holla house my car my boat one of
my houses my car's my boat's my bikes my
books my cameras holiday apartments
rental cars groceries and oak katoa
there's an online platform for almost
anything people can possibly share
nearly one in four people in Germany has
been what's called a co consumer they
swap and share in the sharing economy
the concept of possessions is redefined
a German platform called why own it
caters to this new concept it was
started by Philip Brooklyn who's using
technology to change the face of the
consumer society busy 9 15 minute we've
seen a development in the past six
months and the press and industry are
starting to listen the best part is once
we've got people organized it takes off
in a direction where you can really
change people's consumer habits
currently some 30,000 objects are
available through his iphone app from
books too close to children's toys and
even outdoor items users offer items
they are willing to lend out then they
network with others to see what they
have to share proximity is important
because this social network takes the
words share back to its original meaning
my facebook late when I told us on
Facebook somebody uploads great holiday
photos and everybody admires them with
us you upload a photo of something you
want to share with your friends if you
upload a book for instance you show
everyone you've read it and you can
share it with someone our flight later
you can discuss the book as well and
offline All Stars when Kansas nobody's
looking to hire a Swiss study has shown
that this new form of consumerism is
especially interesting for startups the
sharing economy seems to be more than
just a passing fad in many cities cars
are offered for sharing by the minute
there are now almost half a million car
shares in Germany Airbnb provides a
global alternative for booking lodging
around three million travelers a year
use it to find private accommodations
experts see many advantages in this type
of online sharing these visits mountains
find non-possession makes us freer so as
a society as a person as an individual I
can experience more I can live in
several different cities and always
enjoy a certain luxury or standard of
living because I don't have to own these
things every time
for margarita kazakiewich temporary
luxury is a business concept herp
readily way rents out at Koecher
exclusive clothing and accessories for
about one tenth of what they would cost
to buy the customers can use the items
from four to eight days boquita louie a
lion five customers who rent from preta
Louie don't lack money they consciously
choose not to spend it the items are not
secondhand and each designer pieces
rented out only about ten times whether
on a commercial platform or a social
network the sharing economy is having an
impact on German society convenient for
them you know it's not about doing
without it's about satisfying this
hunger for things by borrowing for a
while I didn't know would actually work
especially in Germany next time a
bargain or a sale looks tempting we
might pause and think if we can borrow
it instead ship says sharing is fun